Stand tall, walk tall, drive tall?
What's up everyone?
I'm Andrew Dymburt with Buzz60.
With car companies' everlasting competition to create more sleek automotives,...
...tall drivers are left asking, "Does this thing even come in my size?"
Balancing comfort, luxury and space is a difficult task for car manufacturers.
Designers use government standards to make vehicles for people...
...within a height span of four foot eleven to six foot two.
That's about 90% of the driving population.
But what about that other 10%?
I may have retired from the game, but not from being big.
Good thing one car gives me full-size luxury.
More cars are offering features like telescoping steering wheels....
...and movable foot pedals to make traditionally small cars...
...like the Kia Soul and Fiat 500L surprisingly roomy.
And other features such as rearview back up cam now make it easier for shorter drivers,...
...to compensate for blind spots.
These items once considered a luxury now typically come standard.
Whatever your size needs may be when shopping for a new ride,...
...it's no longer one tall order.
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.